[Musique]
avec vous Hélène bonjour Hélène bonjour
Pauline dans la presse le durcissement
de la répression en Iran donc où le
mouvement de contestation déclenché par
la mort de Marsa Amini est entré dans sa
quatrième semaine et pour justifier sa
violence le régime profère encore et
toujours les mêmes accusations les
protestataires sont des groupes
terroristes des séparatistes accusés
comme chaque matin ou presque par le
quotidien officiel
Erwan daily qui fait état d'émeutes à
travers tout le pays notamment à
sanandage d'après iron wire site
indépendant la capitale du Kurdistan
iranien vous l'avez évoqué et la cible
d'une répression particulièrement féroce
menée directement par les gardiens de la
révolution qui aurait tiré à balle réel
sur les manifestants cette répression
s'étendent aussi désormais aux
travailleurs de l'industrie
pétrochimique et c'est ce qu'affirme le
Times le quotidien britannique fait état
de plusieurs arrestations à l'usine
c'est dans le sud-est du pays mais il
affirme que c'est très pression n'a pas
touché encore du moins pour le moment
les grévistes de la raffinerie de le
pétrole d'Abadan qui est la plus
importante du pays toujours en tête de
ce mouvement de contestation les femmes
iraniennes restent dans la ligne de mire
du régime
se rappelle que depuis Marsa mini
d'autres femmes sont devenues les
visages de la révolte les victimes de la
répression parmi elles Sarina et Smail Z
et une ado de 16 ans morte le 23
septembre dernier cette jeune fille
aurait été bactu à mort par la police le
crâne fracture à coups de matraque selon
Amnesty International les Iraniennes
dont les dessinateurs de presse du monde
entier salut le courage elle a dégainé
son voile la première justifie un membre
des forces de l'ordre c'est un dessin
signé chapates pour le quotidien suisse
Le Temps dans celui de nassrine chez qui
on le voit sont prises en étau tués par
la Constitution de la République
islamique d'Iran les femmes d'Iran qu'on
retrouve aussi dans ce dessin de publier
pas à l'Arabie el Jadid il est signé
Emad age on les voit tabasser par la
police au côté d'un Palestinien battu
lui par un soldat israélien des
répressions distinctes évidemment mais
tous deux ignorer par l'opinion
internationale selon le dessinateur il
rappelle que selon lui l'attention de
l'opinion publique est détournée
actuellement par la guerre en Ukraine
dans la presse également Hélène la
colère de Joe Biden après la décision de
l'OPEP de réduire drastiquement ses
quotas de production le ministre des
Affaires étrangères saoudien cité par
News tente de justifier cette décision
purement économique selon lui par le
fait qu'elle a été prise à l'unanimité
qu'elle permettra d'assurer je le cite
la stabilité du marché de servir les
intérêts des producteurs et des
consommateurs ces explications laissent
toutefois sceptique middle liste high
qui rappelle que cette réduction
drastique aura pour conséquence sans
doute de faire flamber les prix et donc
pas de garnir les caisses de la Russie
le site se demande si en réalité
l'Arabie Saoudite et les Émirats arabes
ne cherchent pas plutôt à tester les
limites d'un nouvel ordre mondial ou les
pays du Golfe sans chercher à soutenir
directement la Russie ne chercherait pas
non plus à la défavoriser et c'est le
sentiment aussi de farine policy
l'Arabie Saoudite n'est pas un allié des
États-Unis à scène le site américain et
Biden ne devrait pas la traiter comme
tel comme une alliée avec la réduction
de la production de l'OPE plus le prince
héritier Mohamed Ben Salman a clairement
indiqué qu'il fera ce qu'il veut
indépendamment des objectifs ou des
intérêts américains sans la revue
américaine
en France toujours à propos de pétrole
ou plutôt d'essence l'opposition entre
le grévistes et des raffineries pardon
et le gouvernement est en train de
tourner au bras de fer engage les
preuves de force annoncent de Figaro qui
applaudit les décisions de la première
ministre de réquisitionner les
personnels pour débloquer des dépôts de
carburant du groupe Essonne Essonne
mobile des dépôts paralysés je cite par
la CGT selon le journal même son de
cloche du côté du Parisien en France qui
dénonce lui les extrémistes de la grève
en précisant que la CGT est faux on
reconduit la grève alors qu'un accord
majoritaire a été signé par d'autres
syndicats en face la Marseillaise
quotidien local qui soutient les
grévistes dénonce on le voit un coup bas
de la part d'un gouvernement qui
chercherait selon lui à tordre le bras
de salariés qui se battent pour des
augmentations face à face à des groupes
j'ai le site qui se gavent sur la crise
alors que le compte 20 minutes le
journal gratuit s'inquiète de voir la
mobilisation dans les raffineries
gagnées d'autres secteurs d'activité une
flamme de fond qui pourra faire donc
tache d'huile cette inquiétude est
partagée par la Croix qui prévient que
l'interdiction et l'accélération pardon
des interdictions touchant les véhicules
polluants dans les zones urbaines pour
être à son tour alimenté une colère
sociale et aggraver donc la fracture
automobile on ne se quitte pas là dessus
Hélène mais que veut exactement Kylian
Mbappé je sais que la question vous
taraude Pauline avant de vous dire à
tout à l'heure je vous propose de jeter
ainsi la l'équipe qui affirme que oui le
joueur du PSG veut quitter le joueur
veut quitter le PSG j'en perd en l'état
et que non la faux qui a été révélée
hier par le quotidien espagnol Marca
n'est pas une surprise là où ça se corse
c'est que le club lui ne veut pas
entendre parler d'un éventuel départ
donc l'affaire n'est pas tout à fait
réglé ce qu'il est en polyné je sais que
la question vous hante aussi l'esprit
alors c'est la date du couronnement de
Charles III prévu le 6 mai prochain
selon The Times ce qui précise que le
service sera plus court et plus simple
que le couronnement de la reine
Elizabeth II en
1953 l'un par l'autre reste merci
beaucoup